welcome to architecting startups with
google cloud a series where we feature
the latest and greatest startups
customers and how they are architecting
and deploying their production
production-ready workloads with gcp
my name is felipe madella and i lead one
of the customer engineering teams
focused on startups here on google cloud
today i have the pleasure to talk to
dan
schlosser he's the co-founder and cto of
embrook company that is innovating in
the agricultural space and has a mission
to
couple sustainability and profit for
farmers
thanks for your time today then and
welcome to the show
thanks so much felipo i really
appreciate being on here and yeah
excited to talk about uh how we use
google cloud
perfect so i would love to start a
little bit diving into what umbrook does
and if you can also share a little bit
the story behind how everything started
sure thing uh ambrook builds farm
accounting and spend management software
we
help farmers manage their finances and
grow their margins to enable them to
make investments that they need to be
more sustainable and profitable that's
our broader mission making
sustainability profitable
yeah the original idea for ambroke was
our ceo mckenzie's
her parents both worked at the usda and
so she grew up with ag policy
conversations at the dinner table
and when studying climate change at
stanford a few years back she learned
that there is a virtuous cycle between
profitability and sustainability in many
natural resource industries and
especially agriculture
in ag better soil health water
conservation and climate resilience
often leads to lower costs increase
yields and price premiums for crops or
livestock so to reduce the
upfront cost and knowledge barriers to
implement these practices the things
that are you know holding farmers back
from becoming more sustainable and
profitable she realized that there was
an overlooked part of their operation
back office paperwork and finances were
really hard on farms today and
you know we think we can make this much
simpler and save farms a lot of time and
money so that that's really where our
mission came from we're building
easy-to-use bookkeeping software with
tools and spending cards to save
producers time and money
uh i mean sounds amazing and i love the
innovation in particular in this space
i would love to understand a little bit
more just to give a little bit more
context to the uh to those watching this
what's the experience look like for a
user using a platform like where first
of all how do they find you and then
typically it's this like consumer or or
a business that's going to be looking
for your platform and what's the
experience when they actually log in and
what do they do what do they see
sure yeah absolutely um many ambra
customers find us through our funding
library which is a free resource that we
publish that is the largest collection
of farm
grants loans cost share easement
programs on the internet they can fill
out a quick survey share more about
their operation
then create an account with us to get
recommendations for which funding
programs might be a good fit
uh we
have provided this resource for free for
over a year now and
we're
inviting a small number of those
producers to
actually onboard to our uh bookkeeping
and cards product that's in development
right now we have a small group of
trusted testers that are
building with us they're our design
partners we call them and we onboard
these farms onto ambrook's bookkeeping
software we connect their bank accounts
any finance software they use and and
their sales point of sale system like
square
to remove the need for any double entry
once they're all set up they get to use
ambrook which means much simpler
bookkeeping all their transactions from
their cards or bank accounts that they
have linked show up in ambrook they can
tag transactions not just with the
categories that they need to file taxes
or perform annual reports but also with
the commodities or business lines that
they need to understand their business
they can itemize transactions take
photos of a receipt and and will
actually uh parse out all the details so
they don't have to write them all down
if they you know went to the store and
bought 40 different things we can just
parse that out automatically and then
with all that data captured and well
organized in ambrok
these producers can see the breakdown of
what they're spending on be that uh you
know how much am i spending on seed
versus electricity versus water versus
bedding or
you know what is the profit and loss of
each of my
business lines that i operate so you can
make decisions for next season
uh perfect thanks thanks for sharing i i
when i hear
uh it sounds uh like it we're
we could break this architecture in
several ways the applications but as we
were discussing previously seems that
you really took like a lean approach on
how you architect
and and you approach the infrastructure
behind this application so could could
we go a little bit deeper now on the
architecture side like your your
decisions
around
how would you would build on gcp use
cloud in general and just go a little
bit distill what's your infra or your
stack application stack look like today
yeah absolutely uh one of the one of the
things that we were thinking about most
when we started
making some of our earliest architecture
decisions was how could we
avoid a trade-off between
moving quickly and picking the tools
that were going to last a long time and
really stand the test of time as our
product develops and so
we leaned into google serverless tools
because we wanted to be able to move
really quickly with a lean team
we also chose
typescript and next.js as well as react
native so that we could be we could
build our app across web android and ios
while sharing types and code and
ui
components
and not have to write them multiple
times uh we chose google cloud run and
firestore so that we can uh have a
really performant experience for our
customers while also not feeling like we
were on a sort of
set of prototyping tools that we it was
sort of inevitable to move off of and uh
yeah a year and a half later we're we're
still on cloud run firestore so um so
far so good
perfect okay
i think to help us understand
uh kind of the the flow
of your user journey if we were like to
follow like this http request or like
how what's the
behind the scenes
components and how do they communicate
with each other if you could just walk
walk us through it would be great
um sure maybe we could start at the
front uh our
customers access ambrook through our web
android and ios apps which are built in
typescript and react and react native
these
applications talk to our web api which
is built in our monolithic next.js web
application which is written in
typescript
we deploy that web app on google cloud
run using docker and we have several uh
services configured for production both
static and dynamic as well as staging
environments
our load balancer sits in front to
direct traffic deciding which request
should be passed to which services and
passing others onto our cdn which is
also run by google
we spend a lot of time optimizing for
performance here
next.js allows us to serve static and
dynamic content server-side rendered and
statically generated
all in one application where we get to
make a decision for each page what the
right experience should be
by pairing this with cloud run services
that are shaped to handle these
different kinds of traffic
we've been able to achieve great
performance across a variety of
different request patterns
we use firestore for application data
firebase auth for authentication and
authorization and google cloud storage
for blob storage
not everything we do can be done in just
the 200 milliseconds we aim to have all
of our http requests return in though
to manage asynchronous work from receipt
parsing to data syncing to document
generation we use google cloud task
queues
we put workloads on these queues either
with cloud functions or from the app
itself
the tasks use schedule requests to be
sent back to our monolith which holds
all the business logic for example when
a new transaction occurs on an inbrook
card we'd write a new record to
firestore
that firestore document creation
triggers a cloud function which enqueues
a post request back to our monolith to
an endpoint that will send an email
notification to all the relevant parties
based on their notification preferences
this lets us have all the business logic
in one place and not
have to deal with deploying
different versions of business logic
across different services or
microservices
now
there's a lot that goes into running the
ambroke product our team uses a suite of
internal tools and dashboards and we
like to manage and monitor
our app
as much as possible in order to support
our customers
we have internal tools built with retool
as well as data studio dashboards
that are powered by a combination of
production databases and database
exports that are imported into bigquery
thanks then i i love the way you're
setting up your architecture very simple
again
taking advantage of our serverless
capacity to have a just a quick quick
life cycle of your deployment there now
when i see like handling transactional
finance data we our mind almost defaults
like to a sql uh type of database and of
course you're using firestore firebase
which shows a lot of the power that he
has especially like for startup you
innovating quickly
so
what was the decision
criteria like what was the rationale
behind going with firebase from from the
start
yeah absolutely um the decision to go
with firestore over a sql database was
one to optimize for speed without
sacrificing user experience
i had used the firebase realtime
database in the past which was
phenomenal for getting a you know a
project done in a weekend or something
but
what we wanted was a database that would
serve every request really quickly while
also letting us
move quickly and adapt based on the
needs of our customers changing uh in a
startup the only thing that's constant
is change so
we didn't want to be doing sql
migrations every week you know as we
added new features
firestore has been really amazing from a
performance perspective and it's allowed
us to
do the kind of complex queries that we
need to power our experience
that that decision is hold up and and we
may introduce some sql databases in the
future but uh so far firestore has
served us well
dan this is great actually this is the
purpose of these conversations is so we
can see all the different use cases uh
that we have to particular startups
and is there any other
features that in firebase they're
leveraging outside of the the whole
speed on the transaction the reads and
writes that you mentioned um
is there anything else that today you
think it's uh have been a piece of
innovation for your product
yeah absolutely um
for us firebase authentication has been
extremely powerful uh it
uses jwts
that allow us to authenticate requests
both on the server side and client-side
navigation uh it made it super easy to
set up google facebook and password
authentication as well as anonymous
authentication
that anonymous auth has been especially
useful for our free tools
because
when we
start
asking people about their operation we
don't want to say
welcome to ambroke please sign up to
learn more about funding programs we
want to be able to say hey tell us about
your operation and then if you want you
can create an account to see your
recommendations that uh
that that anonymous authentication that
happens right when they first visit the
page allows us for to ask for
information just in time rather than you
know putting up a wall up front before
we get to uh ask them to
tell us more
now it makes a lot of sense again once
more i think you're prioritizing your
your the user experience and also uh
probably as an audience that you want to
make sure that you're providing
the friendliness of your platform before
anything else and so if we talk about
the actual the audience in this industry
one of the things like for gcp users
like our customers is that we at the end
of the day we just want them to thrive
in whatever industry they're choosing
the ag industry has evolved over the
years on the technology side but it
seems
that you're innovating quickly kind of
outpacing usually the industry's
innovation itself
do you think there is like the way
you're approaching your your technology
decisions is it helping with this or how
how are you
innovating so quickly on this
yeah absolutely uh i think ambroke is a
company that really could only be built
today uh four years ago there there was
no plaid no stripe uh we're we're
building this company on top of fintech
platforms that allow us to offer
a amazing user experience to a a
vertical that has not really been built
for in this way by fintech before today
we
are building on top of these platforms
because we don't want to be building
infrastructure we want to be helping our
customers and so building a top of
google building on top of stripe
building on top of plaid has allowed us
to move incredibly quickly and
ship products that are actually helping
farmers today rather than spending uh
what you might have done five years ago
which is spend three years building all
the infrastructure and then start to
start to build product
then it sounds great i think the the
innovation
speed has a lot to do with how your
building and the technology are using of
course so can we talk a little bit about
your deployment process how you're
approaching
and is there any insights that you would
like to share
yeah absolutely uh we really care about
being able to deploy quickly at ambrock
it doesn't matter how quickly you write
the code if you're constantly
having to
fix breakages in production or run tests
manually to make sure that your latest
change isn't going to break things for
customers so
we set up a testing and automation suite
that runs on every pull request we use
google cloud build and deploy
each pull request in github using github
actions to a
unique
subdomain of our
google cloud run staging environment so
each change you can confidently just
click the link and go see what the
change would look like if it were
deployed
we also build our react native
application and have a qr code where you
can pull up your phone scan that
revision and any some any person that's
reviewing a pull request can click a
link and see the web experience
scan the qr code and see the native
experience
and and also see that all the tests are
green
so
when
those pull requests are merged we
build the app run tests and
automatically deploy that to google
cloud run
without having to worry about any manual
deploying process
this is something we invested in early
it in my experience
if
once you get in the heat of building
product it can be hard to prioritize
infrastructure so we did that first and
it has absolutely paid off uh we deploy
our web application multiple times per
day and our android and ios apps every
day
at that and that's something we're
really proud of yeah i know exactly what
you're saying once you have your first
version of
beta or production ready application you
hardly find the time or even the
rational to go back and change your cicd
process or it takes a lot of work so i'm
glad that you uh sharing that starting
that early makes a lot of difference
and i'm sure you faced a lot of
challenges on the way anything in
particular you would like to highlight
so we can share that it's not all about
roses but we have some torns as well
along the way
uh definitely uh we definitely hit our
share of challenges um
i would say that most of them are
were around working with nexjs which
especially when we were getting started
was a relatively new uh javascript
framework and had a fairly small
community of developers that were
deploying it uh to google cloud
our original application used app engine
that was the first thing that i thought
of to deploy next js um because it was
super easy to set up you know we had it
up in like an hour
but uh one of next js's most exciting
features is incremental static
regeneration that allows us to
statically generate content at build
time and then when updates happen have
them regenerate without having to
redeploy
the thing is if your regenerating static
content you need to be able to write it
to disk and app engine doesn't do that
so uh we had an issue where we were you
know scratching our heads and saying
why isn't this content updating like you
know and it actually had led to a 404
because we had moved something from one
page to another page and we were like
why are these four fours happening
and uh then we realized that it's a
read-only file system so uh to fix that
issue we moved our application to google
cloud run there was a thankfully a
pretty simple tool to auto generate the
config for cloud run from an app engine
app and uh we were redeployed in a few
hours and we've been on that happily
ever since
but uh yeah it was a little scary in the
moment to be like wait a minute we have
to change our server deploying platform
like that that's gonna take forever but
it ended up being uh
simpler than we had originally thought
so
looking to the future
then what are any technical enhancements
or anything that is your own your
roadmap
planned for
for for the future
yeah uh two big ones come to mind the
first is task queues uh as i mentioned
we have a
we use google cloud tasks for our
asynchronous work but today we use a
single queue for all of our different
kinds of asynchronous
tasks in the future we think we will
probably want to have a different queue
for each task type so that
we can tune them for the correct
sort of qps expectations retry behavior
and things like that
we also are operating on a single
production and then staging environment
in google cloud run but our core app
doesn't understand the difference
between these two environments and our
database isn't
set up separately for different
environments which is something that we
know we're going to have to do
that will probably involve creating a
new google cloud project id and
duplicating all those uh services but uh
yeah we'll we'll be doing that in time i
think
this is awesome so thanks for for
sharing and also we're getting to the
end of our conversation it's been an
awesome awesome chat so thank you very
much for your time then so how do people
learn about uh ambrook if they want to
reach out and and and get to know a
little bit more about the company
yeah absolutely uh thank you so much for
for having me i love getting to
share the amazing work that our
engineering team is doing um uh yeah
people that want to learn more should
definitely check out ambrook.com
research where we write about our
company and and the the work that we're
doing internally as well as uh really uh
interesting original research on the
agriculture industry uh and uh if
interested in learning more about the
company they can
check out ambrook.com careers and we're
absolutely hiring so uh yeah definitely
check that out um yeah thanks so much
for having me philippo appreciate it of
course it was our pleasure then and it
was we learned so much at how ambrook is
innovating the ag space and providing
this unique experience for farmers so
they can focus on their
main operations which is to be in the
field and also we loved how you're
approaching your quick development and
the way you're approaching your your
database usage and your ci cd
if you enjoyed this video series please
make sure to click and subscribe so you
can stay tuned to more episodes of
architecting startups with google cloud
you